hello and welcome to video playing
freedoom ok or not you never know what
they actually going to make a move on or
they do again Wow c4 I don't see that
too often and especially when black is
still very flexible here wow wow and
what about you dark squares buddy don't
you worry about your dark squares I
guess it doesn't ok so there may be no
here trade this off no worry in the
world should be three okay
I can do many things you can also take
up to 90 for a couple of good options
here maybe do this okay
yeah it's that dangerous can't really
believe in it this age finds stuff i
have got fantastic bishop on the forum
and the bishop pair or as well this is
this this move prepares queen to be six
or queen 285 and keeps d5 under control
yeah he simply ignores ignores what I'm
doing here why look at the opponent's
ideas okay um a couple of things that
are interesting just create five I guess
we so I guess be five right let's attack
ok so Ruby ate up the rupee eight should
be ok so what now t5 takes TX and 5
looks most logical here opening up
everything
yeah I just have to open every possible
file against his against this king I'm
always ready to Castle up the aid
now you can take with the Queen sc3 is
hanging politics there is some rook c8
and this pin looks decisive even bishop
see frequency 325 already looks very
dangerous but it's probably not decisive
yet after politics I think ever probably
castle and getting a new look not rook
c8 i can go rook c8 but rook see one
then doesn't feel entirely decisive if i
take now on c4 is playing Queen c6 hmm
which is kind of kind of annoying it's
actually quite kind of interest it's not
interesting move to be honest if I
casually can maybe play 95 and continue
this this is the stuff if I take on c4
there is this check on c6 just
definitely a bit a bit annoying okay I
think our castle it's not it's not ideal
the good Devils a good defense probably
kings ii do okay um how to do this now
he's not threatening much 97 maybe of
course i can take the exchange well this
is such a strong piece that bishop I
don't really want to take it
yeah probably i will and now not it's
not easy he has Knight f6 and then
stings like that ok Knight f6 takes
takes King kind of dangerous
okay get out of checks here and see what
happens okay take that pawn I don't know
if I want to trade Quincy in this
position I still feel that I should keep
attacking options open against this king
my time is not looking that great hmm my
king see to wast was really good I mean
objectively I think black is better the
whole time but it looked like it should
be like a checkmate or moved 20 enter 23
or so and now we all look 23 and is not
checkmated so it's um it's definitely
better than I thought it should be for
him I mean
it's got a ton of porns them
time warning check taking is not working
right it's close but it's not not quite
working taking on b3 I mean
p hook t5 isn't working or what I can
you have to play that now
I rented that only type checker after
that that's awkward check
check yeah that wasn't very deserved but
it's loving white resides I didn't play
that well game really really should be
over around here and I didn't manage to
kill this off okay this how do I
actually kill it off should age three
and then before this win but that must
win as well I don't believe it I really
don't believe it okay look we ate here
wins but this is not winning it's hard
to the leave from piayed this and now
yeah this is not really not that great
it was a good reply and King see to wear
that was a good reply after King situ
it's not winning anymore really nice
when it's good for black but not like
minus three or so and this is a minus
three position so d5 is says it is a so
logical it cannot be bad but here I have
to castle this is a lot stronger now I
have stuff like that and then the whole
the whole position is blasting opener
something like this and this is going to
be the size of a check the way it was he
managed to keep it somewhat closed this
is really i mean okay helo he lost the
exchange that's clear but this is uh at
least continuing this game and okay the
engine gives minus one and everything's
cool it's not easy it's not easy at all
and here maybe the computer wants to do
this okay i thought about this but i
felt okay let's take the exchange to get
get something but okay of course his
knight on d5 is very strong and he has a
porn so that is definitely not a problem
for Wyatt and Tim yeah I mean I really
went for for activity trying to back try
to attack him but the blue she is
objectively winning for him and a six
and now this awesome I really did you
see what else
to do any Queen III now is this winning
I guess and this is chosen he has to do
this and here I have checks jatin i'm
running out of checks and now wyd wins
with the airport so a very badly played
game by when me I should have just been
after the opening which was well this is
just unplayable really it is just
weakens far too much this is kind of
thing to what I got yo asses immense
bishop on d4 against the night and a
kept weakening its position so this is
here um yeah this should win for black 5
and I was happy with this I think this
is okay even though I mean okay Ruby 8
is given by the compass immediately
decisive but okay yeah rook c8 and it
also its decisive but I have to find
Castle cking c2 is a very strong move
really strong the point is I cannot take
here right because he has a check and
this is getting really weird you have to
move the King now so this is not not
great pink and this is nothing at all I
mean here I'm not even better yeah it's
hard to not trade queens now this is
hanging with check any chance Red
Queen's you've traded down to a position
where all of a sudden he's happy that is
king is kind of participating in the
game very weird okay well thanks for
watching